what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we thought we were gonna
watch Mario today because we mistakenly
thought it came out as Early Access but
Amazon Prime was misleading explaining
the outfits but we're gonna watch Jack
reach her episode six instead even
better I say so guys you know what to do
leave a like for John for all the hard
work he does around here do it for John
put in the comment box as your favorite
thing about John Reacher over here go
ahead and do it also subscribe click the
notification Bell to see John react to
episode 7 of Jack Reacher the TV series
hey thank you to all who have already
joined our patreon page become super
sexy rejects for this show alone but we
also cover so many things exclusively
over their reaction highlights and watch
alongs included for John guys let's get
into it
for John
and the handiwork done to kleiner's neck
it's clear the South Americans are from
Venezuela
damn Dutch angle that's a Venezuelan
butterfly cut makes usf68 bleed out
simultaneously so you effectively drown
in your own blood and you can't learn it
anywhere else when's the last time you
were on a Stakeout climb a compound
change in leadership can result in
mistakes
if it does I want to be watching when it
happens
plan everyone in town knows mine and
you're a Bentley is in subtle it was a
Bentley stupid
this is Station House
the dong has officially had the fan just
curse Finley
now I wanna go eat at jolene's now where
was he found office secretary discovered
him this morning okay assume County
forensics are already there
hey buy anything nothing yet not my
fingerprints or anything and a hair my
dad's guilty you're a piece of [__] easy
nice you're trying to Sully the name and
reputation of a man who has done nothing
but gift to this community I know you're
emotional and I'm sorry for your loss KJ
but I've never done anything in this
town but my job KJ totally murdered him
Thief kill his dad next in line for the
throne a little Joffrey over here I
think KJ did it hold off going to the
crime scene just hit you accuse this
town's fairy Godfather of homicide only
to find out he's a victim like all the
others he could be both sure so hit the
bench
I'll call you back in the game soon
enough is he using NBA analogies because
he's black that's right man that's the
only way he thinks he can get through to
him that's why he doesn't want him to go
to the crime scene and get accidentally
arrested for being black hmm
good guy he's a real hero just need the
windows tinted
three days at least I guess I'll need a
loner then yeah we don't do lovers what
do you do
guess you can take my car by the time
being
it ain't a Bentley but uh it'll get you
from A to B
oh God it's like to cover that Black
Keys album how's she doing Mr Mosley
stay here
why should I let anyone drive me from my
town
only way they're pushing me and my
sister out is in caskets foreshadowing
why you ever came here in the first
place
my Grave's a long way from Harvard
Square detecting city boy that's the new
business
his wife is living here and he's stalked
her I'm gonna inquire about your
personal life but if you inquire about
mine it's none of your goddamn business
you hanging on
I'm hanging on past red hope you know
how to play Settlers of Catan it's Board
Game Central in here let's go this place
was used for Mob witness once
door's been reinforced good alarm system
but use your instincts you feel any
danger you grab that family and you run
just put them on your back
beef jerking in an enclosed space
protein iron sink
doesn't spike your insulin
love jerky that's all I eat jerk Reacher
some missed marketing opportunity right
there so what's the deal with the 110.
Army let me put together my own special
investigations unit
there were nine of us there are the rest
of them no idea pretty cool
barely talk to your brother for years
fall out of touch with your army Buddies
how do you let go of people so easily
you don't it's not healthy you're one to
talk move on Finley
I've seen trees lose Rings faster than
you
as a bar
my wife's dead
well I feel bad about that joker
no matter a lot of a lot of jokes
is that why you left Boston you try
living in a city where every place you
look some memory
of the love of your life all the kick in
the gut oh yeah
that's harsh no I pay a mobile bill each
month
so I could hear her on the voicemail
we eat suit in Georgia in the summer
taking a job in the middle of nowhere
it's all some kind of penance for you
not being able to save your wife
something like that tighten your silly K
you're that stupid
thank you
hey
you should do that more often
double [__] you twice
the beginning of a beautiful beautiful
friendship ah Rigs and Murdoch
Kleiner was murdered less than 24 hours
ago now his nephews aren't making
deliveries it's a lot of animal feed go
to sleep the nightmare start I miss
their dad Thanks again nightmares
I lost my dad when I was a kid too
him my mom both episodes about loss yeah
and family my Memaw would read me Harry
Potter
because Harry is told that his parents
died in a car accident but really
they're Wizards your dad trying to save
him and make the world a better place so
that's when I started to hate
transgender people
[Laughter]
here it is gunfu let's go
spooky get the girl's shoes on and wait
by the Cellar Door you hear me yell you
take off for the woods and don't stop
running
oh come on I can't take another Bull
song this is T-Bone Walker I thought
t-ball was white you sure he was black
T-Mobile brunette was white
Walker was Black come on Finley
no way what's up Supernatural
[Music]
don't you cry no more
no no
no I see it's a recap of Jack Reacher
now how to say all right guys don't get
there doing rock out
thank you Finley I've been waiting for
someone to say so
look Venezuelan
those guys have good hearing I think
their windows are down
oh
I gotta start sending these guys in more
than pairs
oh this is intense yeah
out of the Fog
oh god oh man I'm gonna lose
yes
not too far east from here maybe the
first mile Mark you come to oh
Roscoe can't die not so episode 8.
when everybody dies
Nice Shot damn well done how'd you get
such a good aim in the night holy crap
she knows this place like the back of
her hand
wolf
is that a flash grenade
oh
smart
oh Jesus oh no no let's go gory
still satisfying sure
let's do this
I would wait like just five more minutes
yeah tops of these trucks are made
within vinyl to reduce the weight
God he knows everything
yes a ton all the research
yes
so my two minute nap now it's time to
get back on the road this is having a
smoke break
what a cut truck driver yeah
he's no truck driver
oh jeez dude
I have point inspection it's like a
video game yeah
oh
uh this is just that suspicious
must be I mean I guess it pays to be in
this profession
back to immediate sleep said just wait
five more minutes
wait until they're like in REM sleep you
know yeah you got time truck's empty
it's a shell game it's a dummy it wasn't
shipping money out
what is he doing besides driving around
for hours to deliver nothing he's
picking up we talked to the people who
are helping Joe
the professors they're unreachable not
anymore Jack unreachable
I was looking for William Bryant uh
who don't even know how to say
good morning this morning woof I've lost
track of what this case is
[Laughter]
so much happening yeah
so they didn't get to both
hi reached my voicemail I'm dead
to Jack Reacher you were working with my
brother Joe
I'm coming to New York now do everything
I'm about to tell you if you still want
to be alive by the time I get there
that's the call you want to receive can
you give me just like 30 more minutes
been a long night I've been working on
these kids all night long it's like I
should twisted our ankle you rolled the
ankle good didn't you
tell you what here's my ankle
all aboard the Conklin Express you okay
ready one two three get up there
this was a ploy to get a piggyback ride
who's tougher in the Hubble ladies
Jack Reacher
and all these Venezuelans they keep
sending to try and kill you guys
all the people that misbehave and Mark
grave
put you in your grave
they're out cold
it's time for her to reveal some Secrets
oh here we go I don't know how we got
here
we aren't bad people
I know that but she knows some come on
they're knocked out cold say some [__]
spill it
and everything he told you
was alive she already knows I have known
wait where my
where am I ever question my relationship
with my husband
Mr Kleiner wanted to meet Paul
Paul was excited oh my God an actual
flashback I worked around towns that
you've been interviewing for positions
at other institutions
I would love to throw cleaner Industries
hat in the ring that's incredibly
flattering
so turned on I understand your
hesitation something new
unexplored definitely illegal I got a
big clients in Venezuela
see if this is a line of work that might
be up here alley two weeks pay
one day's work
the American dream I'll never should
have gone to Venezuela you were able to
move that much currency in just a few
hours
you sure this was all legal
a paper four times your current salary
plus a 50 year-end kicker wow now these
are animals that are used to running as
hard as fast as they can one day they're
locked in a stall and they Revolt one
day
they just stop we pay them a lot of
money they know there's nothing they can
do to escape their fate
and they realize that their new life
isn't that bad you know what I'm telling
you this
because this is his new life that money
that you move today there's every cent
of every dollar was tied to an
international counterfeiting scheme of
which you are now part whoa what a dick
I'm able to pay you so far above market
value because frankly
I am my own printing press jeez what a
dick I have your email your IP address
your work product
you
are in this now that's so messed up is
that entrapment I can't do this can't do
what can't get rich beyond your wildest
dreams for just banging away in your
laptop
Jesus I'm going to protect you from
yourself thank you I'm Gonna Leave You
in here for a while what a master
manipulation that you don't run off and
do anything stupid so I've gotten every
guest on the channel
don't knock the gate
you know he was a good man yeah
poor Paul I hope he ran away and he's
just hiding I feel like he could still
be a lot like they've made so much out
of him being dead I feel like he's just
hiding
oh
that's hilarious
put him in there long enough to accept
his fate uh
God you're gonna make him a witness to
this too please this is what happens to
you and your family oh they're gonna
have him witness all of this yeah
yeah that's like some Narco [__] if I've
seen narcos I would know the reference
I'll be with you until we can figure out
what to do next okay damn card's dead
yes sir
laughs it's got to be very rewarding to
be able to do that
Richardson spent two weeks learning to
stay that long that one line I need a
suit I don't know I have enough fabric I
don't have time for jokes I need
something now it's not that big yes
a little too big
interesting
break them in what is he studying
studying I'm here to see my client
Stephanie Castillo I believe she's under
your protection I'll fill you in after
she and I speak
it was wrong it's not season surrendered
it's okay
she'll show up soon enough there really
was something in the water that reached
your house huh
we were the only two academics in the
U.S specializing in the theoretical
effects of muc mass undetectable
counterfeiting on a global economic
scale whoa jeez do you know that 80 of
existing U.S currency is in hundred
dollar bills eighty percent of the money
that I see every day it's not C notes no
where's all that cash abroad
underground economies drugs arms human
trafficking animals well there are
security features
but all of that if someone is determined
and talented enough all of it can be
replicated
reverse engineered they're not making
money in Venezuela and shipping out to
the US they're making money in the U.S
and shipping out to Venezuela how are
you going to take down whoever's doing
this
painfully sure
what branch of the military were you in
army first lieutenant major Jack Reacher
I need your help Lieutenant my brother
Joe Reacher worked in secret service you
can look them up but you'll see I'm not
one to waste time or make up stories you
made up a story
I think about what I have to hahaha it
needs to be off the books it needs to be
quiet
I Can Count On You Diaz
so yes sir God I gotta joined the
military and a loyalty for nothing no
Brotherhood seems as rich and rewarding
I'm calling a favor anywhere
don't throw it out there's no point of
throwing it dude
give it to like three homeless people I
was getting ready for a fight
yeah
yeah I get that frame rate going yeah
frame rate fight
foreign
Jack Runner Tom Cruise run
that's not exactly a Tom Cruise Room go
higher somewhere between Ezra Miller
nice graffiti in this episode
nice nice nice
oh yeah
hello
oh yes yes come on use the tie let's go
that guy's right arm and this is messed
up yeah oh
lovely oh my God that guy's head's gonna
crack All the Way backwards
paired in the sky
cool Jack Strangler
it's New York they would do nothing all
those people living in those buildings
they would do nothing a big old rat just
come over and drag him away
what an image
jeez boy
oh boy
oh boy hold on guys my phone was blowing
up is there something important I know
jeez gosh because everybody wants to you
know talk to you man everyone's just
excited for their great time each day
[__] annoying
it's okay we can take them out one by
one everyone needs to leave me alone
including you guys everyone stop just
stop bothering me stop Greg stop Greg
look at me I want your view comments but
not your actual interaction right stop
bothering me that's right
and please all of you people okay
okay
I thought they figured out on the truck
when there was nothing in there that
they were delivering something to them
or that they were like picking something
up
oh yeah they thought they were picking
something out yeah yeah but either
either either way that's that supports
their idea that they're picking up stuff
from Venezuela but they're they're
bringing the money to them yeah so I
don't know they said there was nothing
in there yeah so I'm like it's not a
little hole that he looked through that
one little hole
I'm sure that big uh airtight light
tight box looks empty
did you have a match to throw in yeah
that was interesting but uh maybe it's
the shell game or something maybe they
know that they're following the trucks
well I like the what's his name Hubble
Hub Hall yeah Paul Hubble
Paul
I think Chanel White
I laundered counterfeit money uh Paul
Hubble and Kleiner scene that was cool
that was a really cool one it does
remind me of a lot of movies and stuff
that I've seen of
specifically the era of like Pablo
Escobar times when they were
handling Coke traffic and all that stuff
there's a kind of a bit of that Vibe but
it was neat to see the backstory to that
and you understand why Mrs Hubble would
not
like her reasoning made a lot of sense
to to hide it especially because she too
was in fear of what could happen and you
really do see this guy was forced into a
position that took advantage of his good
nature when he he was really just trying
to do the right thing and get a good job
and then to see what happened in prison
as well I feel like he could just be
hiding I feel like he could just be like
run away and he's hiding somewhere I
feel like that's yeah there's a good
likelihood of that because like or she
even knows she could she could probably
know I feel it is yeah I feel like a
just because yeah they keep assuring us
that he is dead but I don't know like
especially seeing that situation from
his point of view I'm like I would come
back and come up with as many
contingency plans as possible because
you just have to imagine that this isn't
going to stay
uh not not good but you know you can't
imagine that it's going to stay in such
a position that he will not be in danger
forever you know yeah so I feel like he
could definitely be hiding now and maybe
he learned something from his time in
this in this Venezuelan experience yeah
poor guy
poor poor guy
he was just so cheery I'm like oh I'm
gonna make good money I'm good of a job
man Skyler The Godfather of margrave
wants to work with me how cool and that
was the first time they show kleiners
truly being a ruthless villain who has
comeuppance I thought that was cool to
actually see like now this guy was a
straight up evil dude when I like that
you have that part of the puzz it's like
we've been chasing him down trying to
pin the you know the guilt on Kleiner
and and it's like okay yeah he's
involved big player not the head player
so that gives you kind of that like I
feel like in a mystery show like this or
any kind of procedural mystery I I think
there's a certain level of like you're
trying to you know like really throw the
audience off by coming up with the least
likely you know culprit and so here it's
like okay that was likely and it made
sense that he'd be involved but it's not
the answer to the question yeah so I
think in the finale Reacher's gonna go
to Venezuela rocking two machine guns
yeah it's just two freaking giant
minions
he rides a helicopter and solo jumps
Outlet to crash into the horse farm ooh
I love it Jack Rambo let's go attack
Rambo yeah and then he gets like a bunch
of uh ex-military folks just to kind of
back him up at random it'll be good this
is Joe guy seems great he's he seems
like an American Saint all around he was
that sounds like the greatest person who
ever walked this Earth yeah he knew what
he knew and he knew what he didn't know
and everybody who worked with him
reveres him
yeah they're willing to put their lives
in the future they may come out to be
like the greatest person ever like they
put him on such a pedestal there the
imagery they put him on makes you feel
like he must be it must have been the
one and only person who was
more Superior in intelligence than than
Jack Jack already seems like a
goddamn genius bulking genius yeah I'm
like what were they like if they would
have to solve some kind of mystery
together
would it just be Jack trying to keep up
the whole time
Roscoe protecting that's cool it's cool
that the the show manages to do both of
being a big mystery like now we're in
New York we've got the Venezuela thing
going on but it still keeps it in this
like small town Vibe like it still feels
connected to being part of a community a
small community
instead of losing sight of that appeal I
think that's a really hard thing to
that's a really hard thing to do because
those are two completely different Vibes
yeah and they managed to not lose sight
of that
and yet I thought everything in Margaret
was all gravy until more gravy I thought
everything was all good in margrave
until recently but people are like you
know kleiner's like a Kleiner uh Finley
is like why would you stay here all this
time like it seems like it's nice as
hell here yeah until all these murders
started happening it seems like a pretty
idyllic small town I mean people might
be a little racist which is bad and
horrible to deal with but also it seems
like a pretty mellow existence out here
did not see that Trope coming of
Finley's wife dead I I usually can see
something like that it's usually a it's
a common Trope but damn they have me
going really seemed like they had a
divorce yeah totally and that and and I
liked I I like the payoff to the mislead
of him calling up and leaving the
message and and and the sweetness like
the heartbreaking sweetness of that of
like I paid for this phone bill just so
I can hear her voice
I guess
feel like there are cheaper ways to do
that but also that's like such a sweet
kind of heartbreaking thing unless you
have to clear her voicemail too
yeah if he leaves too many does he have
to lock in and delete his own
voicemails damn it filled the Box up
again
lonely Thursday
yeah and that is a Trope too
playing the vote I mean I'm sure it
happens in real life
um but that that is a Trope I've seen
several times too where they call the
voicemail
you know to hear their voice again make
you feel like they're they're sending
them a message or connected to them and
they did that and I'm like oh they
planted all the seeds for that
I love the way that scene went down
because Reacher doesn't go all soft
yeah it goes tough or wrong
yeah it's like you could tell he
receives the information but he's not
about to make it yeah like something I'm
sorry
right now like yeah okay like I get a
little bit more about you but also I'm
still gonna but and I love that thing
with him swearing at the end and you
know double double F you twice a cute
moment out of it yeah sweet but Jack
Reacher style and Roscoe being a total
badass real MVP sure enough MVP of the
show sharp shooting in the woods at
night with all them leaves and shadows I
don't think she's gonna die now
it could still happen they could still
castrate her and nail her to a wall
that would be an interesting scene it
would be an interesting scene
but now I'm rooting for I'm rooting for
Orozco
but I feel like she's gonna walk out of
this maybe with one more you know
pretty harsh bit of peril before it's
all said and done well there's too much
personal Stakes for her now too oh yeah
I mean you know her her direct kind of
involvement now but what's the deal with
what's the deal what's the deal with
that
the mayor guy teal teal Bruce McGill he
seems like he actually gives a [__] uh
yes there's something it seems like he
gives a [__] about something like he's
also corrupt but also gives a [__] about
some of this and like yeah I can't tell
what his deal is and I and and maybe now
maybe now it will turn out to be
somewhere in between I've been sitting
here you know obviously I think you're
supposed to go like maybe he's not he's
either evil or he's just absolutely not
and it just kind of looks like he is but
yeah I don't I don't know with him and I
think he's good it's good casting
because he's played so many characters
in these settings on both sides of the
line that I think just having him here
kind of muddies your expectation of what
side it'll fall on sure but I do I can
see a version of this we're just like
yeah he's not like a police law they
made that deal about him you know not
having like police experience so maybe
he's just running it the way he knows
how to run it and maybe that just looks
suspicious given the circumstances
but I like that you know all these
things I can't really tell I can't
really like solidly conclude like nah
I'm still like committed to this Theory
or whatever yeah you know all the and
and two I don't know like that whole
thing with uh the wound on on that guy
Greg's head with Roscoe going back into
the corn uh Corner uh information and
and you know the the Bejeweled staff
looking like a Smoking Gun like I almost
wonder if that's the mislead but then
again I mean Kleiner was uh totally who
they suspected him of being so maybe it
will turn out that he is just one of
these you know bad players
it's well drawn I don't know I can see
it going a number of ways yeah I think
the characters are in really well even
like the random people who show up for
like a scene you know even like Neely
and this professor you know you you a
big part of this is that you're not
going to get a lot of backstory you're
not going to get a lot of time with them
and you gotta have the sense that
they're a fully fleshed out character at
the same time so it requires like a
solid actor to do it as well but also
enough Variety in the dialogue so that
way the the language of it speaks more
volumes in brevity than it does and you
know Exposition so I think that they did
a really good job even that Professor
I'm like yeah I feel like this person's
like really been around the game for a
while yeah that feels like a real
professional same thing with Neely and
so I think they do a really excellent
job uh with that Picard I'm not sure
about him it's the one characteristics
I don't really get the card character
have full history with the guy
obviously seems like a guy he's just
like dude we still want to get fired for
being an FBI
I don't know what to make of this either
because because he's like he's Charming
yeah he's charming and when he shows up
you usually feel pretty safe but also
like the second he leaves you like the
good the assassination attempt goes down
so also I don't know I don't want there
to be a Twist where he's in on it or
something but you know they're all in on
it everyone's the kids the everyone's
Venezuelan is that counterfeit thing
real
I have to imagine it's based on some
kind of real I mean you know people
counterfeit so what do they print money
I love to print money oh yeah go to the
mint how much easier would be to print
money yeah if you just then actually
earn that money yeah just cut out you
know a few pallets of Hondos and then
your life is set you know that'd be a
crazy way to find that spot yeah get
your special it's probably like just so
military backed up oh sure oh sure the
mint I don't know like Yeah It's gotta
be under lock and key and and gun and
knife and there's got to be a moat and
some quicksand and it's a very specific
type of paper yeah people counterfeit
one time I I paid one time when we're in
Colorado
um my mom bought some Baskin Robbins and
then the person had to hail her down and
and they beat her to a pulp house
criminals are down
uh because apparently the the 20 Bill
she paid with wasn't a real 20 Bill your
mom's in on it she's in on it she's
working with the Venezuelans the mule
she's bringing slabs of fake
Jackson's into the states she could I
think I think with the animals that's
how they're that's how they're awesome
in the animal feed bags that's that's
the one detail unless that turns out not
to be I feel like that's the one dot
that they should be connecting it's like
there's a whole lot of animal feed I'm
like what if it's not animal feed but if
it's just they gotta be hiding it in the
animal feed yeah or in the animals
[Music]
we gotta get these cows to [__] out the
money so we can take it back to
Venezuela
you have like a lot of money in there
but I don't know they cut them open or
whatever
should be disturbing I feel like I've
seen something where they do something
like that um oh it's I'm sure it's
happened they hide something in animals
yeah oh oh then you're you're a true
mule that way
but uh
yeah it's good it's good it's keeping
the momentum man keeping the Intrigue
keeping the flavor alive keeping the
good character interactions solid ass
show and then fight scenes to keep your
stimuli up yeah they're not bored
watching this show yeah where's my
Carnage where's my violence person my
Primal expression of Rage
how can I watch Jack Reacher work out
some of his issues
through violence
that was a harsh fight scene too that
that fight scene on the uh
fire escape with the knife and the
bicycle wheel that's cool that's good
I've seen harsher I really did expect
that guy's neck to like
completely snap backwards or dislocate
her or his head to come clean off I'm
surprised Jack Reacher was able to hang
off of his necklace
without it like completely coming off
did you know when John Wick in that
kitchen if I won the when Kiana hits
that guy who's on the kitchen bar table
and his neck snaps back a famous moment
yes that's that man actually is able to
just do that with his neck so they just
threw it into the fight because he's
able to like
contort his neck like that wow so
they're like oh it's throwing into the
fight
well yeah sure at that point like such a
such a icky thing to it looks like it's
really painful so yeah it's working in
any way you can
all right ladies and gentlemen well what
did you think of the Super Mario
Brothers movie I'll leave your thoughts
down below
it's a me it's Jacob
uh subscribe click the Bell leave a like
only got two more episodes left
hopefully we segue into Luigi's Mansion
afterwards yes
Luigi Reacher
see you guys peace